[Music]
what's up gq i'm sean mendez and i'm
going undercover on the internet
this is actually me
twitter
sean mendez said that all the songs he's
ever written were about camila so where
does where were you in the morning fit
into the story
all the songs that were about a person
were about camilla
that song wasn't actually about a person
and that's the truth of being a
songwriter sometimes
sometimes you're writing about something
that didn't happen maybe that you wish
that happened
and that was that song for me what if
monster is justin bieber and shawn
mendes talking about their fame
and the monsters that come with it
monster is more about
how society likes to put celebrities up
on a pedestal but i think
society is constantly putting everybody
up on a pedestal i think because we all
have social media we're always either
putting each other on a pedestal or
tearing each other down and
i think there is a unfair and
not possible expectation for perfection
that people
have to kind of live up to on social
media all the time and
monster is that and it's really just
saying like
what if i trip whatever i fall does that
make me a monster and the answer is no
i really hope that that comes across in
that way because it's a really important
song i think for that reason
okay let's check out youtube
i thought they weren't friends at one
point was that true
justin and i were never like enemies we
were
maybe not friends i mean yeah i guess i
wasn't texting and being like yo how you
doing today
but we wouldn't have our enemies
absolutely that's um
kind of something that people maybe
might have turned it into at some point
when he made that video and he was like
who sean mendes he said he really
genuinely didn't know who i was and i
believed him so
whatever maybe he did and he was trying
to bug me either way
but i mean honestly i really love him
he's been so sweet and super
gracious and giving with his advice and
with his energy so
he's a good friend tick-tock
[Music]
me the first time i made a tick-tock
look that was the third time i made a
tick-tock
and i don't think i'm gonna get much
better i was thinking about just doing
exactly what i did on vine
on tick tock maybe that'll be good boom
bb my grandpa trying to figure out face
time
that's how i feel genuinely i mean when
i go on tick-tock i feel
like a grandpa trying to figure out face
time you have so many filters back in my
day
you just had vine you had one option it
was you could record it
and stop and then record and stop you
couldn't do reverse you could there was
no sound effects
it was the good old days posted
instagram
[Music]
wait did you two just get a puppy
together or that's exactly what we got
we got a puppy together and he's over
here sleeping hey
come here you want to come here no he's
in his i don't listen to anything you
say
puppy face jose you're sleepy
go no not gonna happen sorry guys
tarzan's like 10 weeks right now
but he's growing like super fast he's
looking at me right now he's like really
questioning whether he wants to hang out
or not but
come here come baby you want to say hi
no
this is tarzan he's
he's really dramatic and he's yawning
what are you stressed about
you're tired he's nervous and tired he
gets
camera shy i guess okay i'll put you
down
perfect sean says what's your favorite
track i can't
decide overall like forever what my
favorite song is but currently my
favorite song on that album is
song for no one song for no one ended up
being the pillar
for what i wanted the album to sound
like and i wrote it three years ago and
didn't even know it so yeah and
it's just a beautiful song i mean it's
really heartbreaking and lonely and i
was lonely and kind of heartbroken at
the time and
it sounds it because the whole thing is
one take through and
yeah i love that song seriously no it's
actually me
okay maybe we should go over to
wikipedia see what they're talking about
mendes has been open about his struggles
with anxiety which he disclosed
publicly through in my blood a track
from his third studio album
that's super true i've always been open
about anxiety but it was the first time
that i
really wanted to write about the
severity of it and it was terrifying and
i thought that
a lot of people are going to be like
he's over the top and dramatic and
ungrateful and i actually ended up
getting an overwhelming amount of
love but not only love but like people
being like i needed this song this was
the year i needed this song
and even this year people reach out to
me about in my blood i think it's going
to be one of those songs that
is always necessary because anxiety is
always relevant
mendez started attracting viewers after
he posted a cover from justin bieber's
as long as you love me on the social
video app
vine in 2013 and got 10 000 likes
and as many followers the next day
that's some like
phrase that i said that when i was like
15 that i just stuck to i was just like
you got like 10
000 likes and i had like 10 000
followers the next day um
i don't even know if that's accurate at
all but this is very true i did a cover
of as long as you love me and that's the
video
that made my v vine account blow up so
thanks justin all these years later cora
[Music]
the sean mendes write his own songs i do
write my own songs i wonder if majority
of people think i don't or do
regardless i do that's why i love them
so much
i think i was like probably 15 or 16
when i started writing songs for the
first time
they were really not great and then i
wrote a lot of songs and ed sheeran has
this metaphor about songwriting he's
like it's like an old tap that hasn't
been working for a long time you turn
the tap on
and let the dirty water pour out until
clean water starts pouring out it's like
the same metaphor for writing songs and
i always find that after not writing
songs for a few months if
i want to write again i have to let
myself let that dirty water kind of wash
through before
i got the good ones next when did shawn
mendes start to sing
i started to sing when i was probably 10
or 11 maybe even 12. i genuinely mean
this
i wasn't a great singer my sister would
tell you
that's true but i just loved singing and
i would watch videos of
like bruno mars or justin bieber or ed
sheeran singing and i would sit there in
my bedroom and just try to mimic their
vocal things and found my own voice
through that process
tricky better is this also for camila
cabello this is definitely for camila
cabello and i think i mean i was 17 when
i was writing that song and she wasn't
even in a relationship i just
maybe threw the grapevine heard that she
had feelings for some guy and i was like
i'm gonna write an entire song and do a
video about this
what are you ordering from tim hortons
if i
do happen to go to tim hortons i will
get
most likely a chocolate muffin or one
single timbit
in america you call them doughnut holes
i think or the whole of the donut i
don't know if you sell those in america
munchkins are donut holes timbits all
the same guy
what do you miss most in canada i was
telling camila this yesterday actually i
was talking about how
in toronto there's this camaraderie in
the wintertime that you get
because the weather is really kind of
mean and unforgiving so
people really come together and it's
like the first thing anyone ever says to
each other when you walk into a room is
like
it's cold outside isn't it and it's like
this really nice camaraderie that we
have but you would only understand if
you're
from toronto so i miss that a lot about
canada and my friends and family of
course
you might not believe it but it's
actually me this account is called shawn
is soft
i thought that you don't dance i guess i
was wrong i do dance
i don't know if i dance great though but
you know what maybe i do dance great
maybe i'm a great dancer who knows
i'm not gonna put any boxes on that i'm
pretty sure i was just like
trying to be a tick-tocker i've never
felt like an older man in my life
oh look who's back look who came back
i'm sorry but sean you seriously need to
release a hair routine
how is it structured so fluffy curly
shiny and more how is it how am i doing
today
the truth is it's all about the lighting
and a good haircut and i have the best
hairstylist in the world anna burnaby
she cuts my hair amazing and
she gives me all the products that like
look good in it there's a product that i
use that's called inner sense
and leave-in conditioner then a curl
cream to find her
it's just a whole lot of love i think
the truth about hair is that
you gotta like rock the hair that your
hair wants to be
you can't just force your hair to be
something it's not and that's it you
know
gotta love the hair sean should make one
of those podcasts where he just is
talking about calming things while we
drifting to sleep i would love to do
that
for for everyone and for myself i've
thought about doing a podcast a few
times
the time will come when it's right and
just talk about waves crashing
along the water one day i went on a walk
down this beach and it was gorgeous and
there was a sunset
and i was reminiscing of a friend of
mine from when i was 11 years old
and stuff like that did you know this
song inspired the sound of the album
because his sister was listening to it
and she showed him with
sad faces i did know that and i guess
obviously i knew that but yeah my sister
inspired the album by playing me can't
take my eyes off of you by frankie valli
i owe her one i guess i got a whole
album after that
all right gq that's it i'm signing off
the internet goodbye
love you